da sein logo menschen tun im netz dinge
die sieben irgendwie im richtigen leben
sich nicht trauen ist dass der kern des
problems
ich würde ihm komplett widersprechen und
zwar aus zwei gründen das eine ist dass
das netz ein teil des richtigen lebens
geworden ist gerade mit den sozialen
medien für sehr viele menschen für ganze
generationen die ihr leben so
organisieren dass kann man kaum mehr
trennen
einerseits und andererseits ist glaube
ich genau das nicht das problem
wir leben zwar eine eskalation eine hass
spirale das sieht man das kann man
spüren wenn man anfängt zu recherchieren
dann hängt das sehr oft an bestimmten
zweck in einer rechtsextremen zu können
vor allem aber ich glaube dass man auf
keinen fall den fehler machen zu glauben
aber wir haben das problem da im netz
isoliert das problem ist zuallererst in
den köpfen und so zweiten natürlich auch
an den mechanismen die sich noch ergeben
es ist ja nicht so als sei das alles nur
soziale medien und internet wir haben ja
hier auch einen vertreter einer ganz
altmodischen hass maschine sitzen der
bild -zeitung nämlich und die mechanik
lässt sich sehr gut nachvollziehen
wir haben zum beispiel dieses jahr
erlebt wie die bild zeitung die
entscheidung eines kindergartens in
leipzig kein schweinefleisch mehr
anzubieten groß auf die erste seite
nimmt und auch wenn der artikel selbst
ich fand ihn faktisch falsch wenn der
artikel selbst nicht unbedingt hetze ist
ist die reaktion darauf in sozialen
medien erwartbar hetze und das ist wie
so ein trigger der darein gedrückt wird
und ich finde auch darüber muss man
sprechen und das machen wir schon
[Applaus]
und wir fragen gleich nochmal ob man
wenn man die sprache bekämpft
tatsächlich auch die ursache bekämpft
wie setzen sie sich mit solchen
vorwürfen auseinander ich finde es
einfach erst mal prima dass
wahrscheinlich pablo heute seine
experimente mit dem wort bild machen
würde und es würde sascha lobo anfang zu
bilden aber dass katzen das
unterscheidet uns
ich würde auch keine großen
unterscheidungen zwischen linkem hass
rechten hat und nie so genau was machen
wenn wir so erst anfangen dann wenn wir
bei aufsätzen wie sie auf dem portal des
deutschlandfunks standen hassen ja aber
die richtigen wenn wir so anfangen
dann setzen wir eine spirale in gang die
am ende jedem irgendwie die berechtigung
gibt seiner subjektiven wahrnehmung mit
gewalt nachdruck zu verleihen und das
kann nicht das ziel sein
fast zwei leute geklatscht symptomatisch
wie ich finde wenn sie das schon
zitieren dann würde ich das ein bisschen
präziser machen in diesem artikel wurde
gesagt hast du die richtige mutter von
konkreten nazis gesprochen also menschen
die andere industriell ermorden wollen
und ich finde das wort hass wenn man das
gezielt gewürzt einsatz in richtung von
nazis die andere ermorden wollen dann
ist es nicht ganz falsch aufnehmen so
und dann sind wir noch mal bei rente
sprechen aber sie lieben nazis oder ich
würde einfach niemanden hassen hassen
kann nicht irgendwo eine grundlage bei
einer baptisten zeitung der welt ehrlich
gesagt an die bild zeitung geht aber das
war glaube ich nicht ganz das thema so
wir gehen noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu
der frage igor levit wenn wir
tatsächlich hate speech also gewalt in
der sprache bekämpfen bekämpfen wir dann
die ursache oder hat nicht der hass in
der sprache einen vorläufer eine andere
ursache der sprache ist meiner meinung
nach das was klima macht was anderes
macht klima ist sprache ich meine ich
bin ich habe keine sprache ja in dem was
ich tue ich bin mittlerweile unterwegs
die ganze zeit ich machte musik ich
erzeuge zustände
ja ich kann die nicht erklären aber das
was man erklären kann mit sprache noch
einmal macht klima und hier zu sitzen
und zu sagen na ja
man kann jetzt mal sagen ich weiß nicht
ich richte dich mal hin ist ja oder oder
übersehen irgendwann mit hass und hetze
ist ja vielleicht nicht so ganz schlimm
weil er tut das ja nicht ist wirklich
kein argument weil weil das ist das ist
die saat aus der dann diese taten aus
deren diese taten geschehen und das und
das kleiner zu reden als es ist halte
ich wirklich für gefahr
hier gefällt ist allein tragen twittern
afd besteht aus menschen die ihr
menschsein verwirkt haben
auf nachfrage des spiegels sagen sie sie
bereuen kein brawn ein
das ist damit schießen sie sich aus
jedem humanen diskurs heraus herrschen
also wenn man das menschsein von
menschen begleitet ist man raus
herr schröder ich habe als kind gelernt
in meiner familie und auch sonst das
wort mensch ist ein jedes wort ein
mensch ist ein guter mensch ein mensch
ist ein mensch von ehre und jetzt reden
wir mal über den konkreten fall
da stand ein fdp-abgeordneter ich daraus
bremen oder sogar aus dieser ecke sprach
in der ard
frontal in die kamera und sagte also
hier ist gerade anarchie in meinem land
kreis und in meinem wahlkreis wurde
gerade ein mädchen von einem
afghanischen geflüchteten vergewaltigt
so ersetzt da die axt an das war 2015 es
war er schon eine echt gefährdete
stimmung und dann bedurfte es einer
nachfrage der journalisten
wo ist das passiert und wer war das und
dieses kartenhaus vielen sich zusammen
und der typ konnte nur noch stottern und
sagen jetzt haben sie mich erwischt
entschuldigen sie bitte auf basis dessen
dass ein mensch ein mensch von ehre ist
hat dieser mensch für mich diese ehre
verbirgt und dazu stehe ich dazu habe
ich nichts zurückzunehmen das ist
gefährlich gut bin artikel 1 des
grundgesetzes für sie nicht geht dann
nehme ich das mal so zur kenntnis aber
genau genommen müsste man auch stehen
uns rausgehen hindert sie niemand also
ich jedenfalls nicht also so weit gehen
wir detailliert versuchen die ursachen
zu finden in dieser sendung frau bär ist
das internet
ihrer meinung nach in der lage das
meinungsklima zu verschlechtern oder
macht das internet erst möglich dass
jetzt zur sprache kommt was eigentlich
immer schon da war also verschärft das
internet dieses meinungsklima oder wird
damit nur offenbar war es eigentlich in
der gesellschaft schon brodelte also das
potenziert sich natürlich auch noch
einmal das muss man ganz klar sagen als
ich früher ins gymnasium gekommen bin
habe ich von meinen eltern gelernt passt
auf wenn ihr euch so zettelchen schreibt
die können irgendwann dann mal am
schwarzen brett hängen passt auf also
passt auf dass es auch nicht jeder sieht
und benehmt euch und anstand und so
weiter also der genau das was sie
angesprochen haben was bekommt man vom
elternhaus mit was gehört sich das
gehört sich nicht also ich glaube wir
können uns ganz ganz viele gesetze
einfach sparen wenn der gesunde
menschenverstand wenn im partie da wäre
ich habe mich auf der einen seite
gefreut dass wir gestern durchs kabinett
bekommen haben einen gesetzentwurf zu
einer verschärfung dass es nicht mehr
erlaubt ist frauen unter den rock zu
fotografieren dass es nicht mehr erlaubt
es frauen in den ausschnitt zu
fotografieren dass er strafrechtlich
relevant werden wird dass man wenn man
an einem unfall vorbei fährt keine toten
keine verletzten filmt und ins netz
stellt auf der einen seite ist das schön
dass hier lücken geschlossen werden auf
der anderen seite frage ich mich warum
braucht man solche gesetze überhaupt
warum sind
da muss man erst jemand merken dass ich
einfach nicht gehört so und deswegen mag
ich schon dass ich da was verändert hat
und dass dieses potenzieren was ich
angesprochen habe
ich habe ja auch mich wahnsinnig
echauffiert weil ich dabei war als peter
altmaier seinen sturz hatte beim digital
gipfel habe da auch mitgeholfen bei der
ersten hilfe und wenn man danach die
reaktionen im netz sieht dass da keine
empathie 30 von einigen jahr aber von so
vielen geht eine so schlimme sachen und
ich werde nichts schlimmes wieder was
mir sondern noch was jemand anderem
geschickt wurde wiederholen weil das ist
es gar nicht wer diese schlimmen worte
zu wiederholen
aber wenn man dann merkt dass da keine
empathie ist jemand verletzt sich und
dann wird sich auch noch darüber lustig
gemacht in einer art und weise die so
ehrabschneidend die so beleidigend ist
dass man wirklich fragen muss wie
verroht sind eigentlich manche menschen
und dann eben das was sie fragen 1000
kätzchen 1000mikes für den schlimmsten
allerschlimmsten kommentare die da
abgesondert sind und da stellt sich
schon die frage ist es möglich auch
bestimmte kommentarfunktionen entweder
zu monitoren ist es auch möglich dass es
auch gerade bei plattformen die sich an
jugendliche richten da gibt es eine ganz
furchtbare würde ich meinen kindern hier
laufen zäh lohnen da kann man sich
anonym den schlimmsten dreck schicken
wirklich das ist nur gehässig nur unter
der gürtellinie nur bedrohend und es ist
das ziel auf 12 und 13 jährige kinder ab
und die sind teilweise schon so
abgestumpft weil die so gewohnt sind
dass mit ihnen gesprochen wird dass ihr
davon screenshots machen in ihre ins
raster stellen an der seite ist auch gar
nicht mitgekriegt und ich dann den
eltern sagt lars die gar nicht auf diese
plattformen drauf weil das herz geht
kaputt die seele wird aufgefressen und
deswegen muss man auch neben allen
gesetzen wir können jeden tag neue
gesetze machen wirklich früher anfangen
mit erziehung wird er mit liebe mit
empathie und einfach auch sagen im
elternhaus das gehört sich einfach nicht
da geht es um anstand
[Applaus]
renate künast hat vor gericht geklagt um
übelste beleidigungen die sie innerhalb
des in dem an spiele gezeigt verfolgen
zu können und ein gericht in berlin fand
das wohl nicht so schlimm muss man sich
alles gefallen lassen jenseits von
morddrohungen
wir leben in einer großartigen
demokratie mit einer gott sei dank sehr
starken meinungsfreiheit aber die ende
da wo das leben von jemand bedroht wird
die würde in frage gestellt wird das
endet übrigens im besonderen da ab wo
jemand die verbrechen des
nationalsozialismus das habe ich von
meinen großartigen lehrerin der
realschule in bad urach gelernt
relativiert die shoa in frage stellt der
ende die meinungsfreiheit und da muss es
eine glasklare haltung geben da kann es
keine zwei meinungen gehen wenn ich da
für dich zu der debatte von vorhin kurz
was sagen welches ehrlich gesagt nicht
so ganz verstanden habe ich es gibt ein
schönes zitat von martin luther king hat
man sinngemäß gesagt ich habe bei meinem
leben zu viel hass gesehen als dass ich
selber huston könnte insofern will ich
mich daran ehrlich gesagt nicht
beteiligen es ist auch glaube ich
wichtig dass wir uns unseren methoden in
der art wie wir reden in der art wie wir
kommunizieren von denen unterscheiden
die uns bekämpfen wollen und dieses
diese großartige gesellschaften die
großartige demokratien der wir leben
bekämpfen wollen das eigentlich ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir auch in den
methoden die die rechtfertigen das ja
nicht unterscheiden es gibt ein sehr
schönes zitat von professor karl demmer
der mir gesagt hat die voraussetzung
fürs gespräch ist ja dass der andere
recht haben können wir meinen wenn wir
jetzt alle nur rumlaufen und sagen ich
habe recht und alle anderen sind idioten
und ich brülle jeden kapuzen kümmerst
gespräch die kommunikation der
gesellschaft ein dass die arena war
nochmal ganz und
ganz es geht um ganz banale basics mal
estland ausreden
zumal respekt füreinander akzeptiert
unterschiedliche meinungen so lange sie
auf dem boden unserer verfassung sind
das ist klar
da gibt es eine klare grenze man brüllt
jemand nicht einmal bedroht jemand nicht
und ich weiß gar nicht wie man ich habe
jetzt auch keine andere erziehung
genossen hoffentlich wie die meisten
anderen auch aber sowas nennt man in
einer normalen familie
ich finde man muss das wieder einfordern
und ihre abos nicht reicht es
einzufordern
da erwarte ich dann bitte schön auch
dass polizei staatsanwaltschaften der
politik unseren job machen dass wir klar
deutlich machen
es gibt nicht im rechtsfreien raum in
den sozialen medien im netz oder geld
muss ja selbst diese reparieren wir
müssen noch weil wir über das dann zum
meinungsklima in deutschland zu kommen
ich freue mich ungemein bei uns begrüßen
zu können er ist richter und straff von
verfassungsrechtler und befasst sich mit
dem hass im netz und sie können uns herr
meier helfen dabei warum es selbst für
rechte wie im falle von renate künast so
schwer war oder so schwer ist diese
grenze des sagbaren unsagbaren zu ziehen
warum ja in der tat in dem fall renate
künast zu dem ich im detail lieber
nichts sagen möchte ist es um die frage
gegangen was die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit zulässt und
was nicht und das ist in der tat eine
ganz besonders schwierige rechts
anwendungs frage und zwar deswegen weil
das strafrecht hier nur vergleichsweise
weite spielräume lässt und die müssen
dann ausgelegt werden vor allem in dem
man auf die rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts schaut und die
es ebenso umfangreich und teilweise auch
sehr komplex und das stellt auch
richterinnen und richter vor
herausforderungen und warum gehe ich
straffrei aus wenn ich menschen
schlimmste schlimmste gewalt an den hals
wünschen wenn ich sage der müsste man
mal oder die müsste jetzt mal warum ist
das straffrei da liegen sie in der tat
einen finger in die wunde denn die
billigung fiktiver straftaten ist in der
tat bislang nicht strafbar da müsste man
darüber nachdenken ob das tatsächlich
eine lücke im strafgesetz ist das könnte
man natürlich nach steuern müsste dabei
aber auch wiederum die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit
natürlich beachten aber ich denke wenn
es um fiktive straftaten geht es sei ja
gerade schon angedeutet da ist die
grenze auf jeden fall überschritten
der ist sie überschritten ist die
anonymität im netz aus ihrer sicht der
hauptgrund dafür warum menschen
irgendwie alles fahren lassen
nein das würde ich so nicht sehen
natürlich gibt es einzelne menschen die
sich unter dem schutz der anonymität
hinreißen lassen brutalste dinge ins
netz zu stellen
aber das eigentliche problem denke ich
ist die ausstattung der
ermittlungsbehörden aber auch die
schwerpunktsetzung wir alle wissen
polizei und staatsanwaltschaften sind
extrem herausgefordert und sie haben
vielleicht auch in den letzten jahren
nicht immer den akzent wirklich gelegt
auf beleidigungen
das gibt kann man auch nachvollziehen
die beleidigung ist im gefüge unseres
strafrechts einfach keine besonders
schwere straftat auch wenn sie natürlich
im einzelfall besonders schwere
auswirkungen haben kann
der strafrechtler der straff anwender
schaut auf den strafraum und der ist bei
der beleidigung einfach nicht so hoch
wie natürlich zb saudischem einem
ladendiebstahl unter par zum beispiel
auch ein ladendiebstahl wäre im zweifel
schwerer zuschauer und wenn politiker
dann also sagen das internet dürfe kein
rechtsfreier raum sein dann ist das
eigentlich ein frommer wunsch
nein das ist kein frommer wunsch das ist
ganz im gegenteil eine frage der
politischen gestaltung die insbesondere
die länder müssen polizei und
staatsanwaltschaften so ausstatten dass
sie tatsächlich auch ihren aufgaben
nachkommen können und natürlich müssen
sie mit den begrenzten kapazitäten dann
vielleicht auch einen schwerpunkt setzen
gerade bei der strafverfolgung im
internet
sie haben das beispiel ladendiebstähle
gebracht ich finde man kann mit recht
fragen was denn eigentlich sozial
schädlicher ist ja jemand der als
hassprediger im netzauftritt zum hass
zum beispiel gegen gegen jüdinnen und
juden aufruft oder jemand der mann von
kaffee mit nimmt also verstehen sie mich
nicht falsch ich werde jetzt auf gar
keinen fall straftaten billigen nur wenn
sie an von kaffee mitnehmen können sie
sicher sein dass sie verfolgt werden und
im internet ist das nicht der fall
er ist aus meiner sicht was verrutscht
da ist was für roger
und wenn die punkte im grunde schon
angesprochen alles gemeldet werden soll
was justiziabel ist durch welche richter
und staatsanwälte ist das irgendwie dann
zu sanktionieren also ich sehe das sehr
skeptisch denn wir haben ja bislang die
situation dass selbst die gemeldeten die
angezeigten taten noch nicht effizient
verfolgt werden können ich sehe nicht
dass die strafverfolgung vorangebracht
würde dadurch dass jetzt wie sie es
angedeutet haben zehntausende weiterer
fälle quasi ein blog gemeldet werden an
die strafverfolgungsbehörden im internet
spricht man bei massen zugriffen auf
einen server von einer
denial-of-service-attacke ja zu viele
greifen auf einen server zu der server
kraft zusammen und genau das ist es
wofür ich mich gerade sorge also wenn
man keine wirkliche offensive startet
bei polizei und justiz um diese steuer
diese anzeigen dann auch wirklich
abarbeiten zu können
dann wird die strafe folgen sich
sicherlich nicht verbessern herr bohmann
ja toll dass wir sie heute bei uns haben
und damit sind wir wieder in der runde